the host of michelle malkin investigates
see our TV michelle malkin former deputy
assistant to the president and foxnews
national security strategist dr.
Sebastian corker all right Michelle is
so much here I'm just gonna let you take
it because I know you've got a lot to
offer well the fact is that the
resistance media is shooting blanks and
when they're using crosshairs imagery I
mean they have no self-awareness these
are the people went who went nuts with
Sarah Palin over crosshairs remember
that and now you've got Whoopi Goldberg
essentially rooting for riots I I recall
a time before the election when the left
and the leftists in the media lectured
America when they were so confident that
it was going to be Hillary Clinton that
we had to accept the election results
remember this and we couldn't have any
kind of civil unrest we needed civil
order and now they're cheering for riots
as a result of their empty empty
conspiracy theories and their their
refusal to accept reality I mean if you
are familiar with the Caine Mutiny the
novel captain queeg was the the crazy
guy on board the ship who was on this
fishing expedition for strawberries that
he couldn't find that's Robert Muller
and that's Robert Muller's enablers than
the media as well you know the
complicity here is very key because the
media not looking at the FISA abuses not
looking at Hillary's we know she
committed felonies we know that that she
was exonerated without an investigation
we know she paid for the dossier we know
that the judges the FISA judges will
lied to dr. korkor their focus on Russia
Russia story Karen and whatever else now
the access hollywood tapes they are
complicit in all of this they don't
report the news anymore they don't do
investigative work anymore but Sean I'm
not sure they ever really did I mean
they look at the last eight years what
did we see during the Obama
administration just outrageous
sycophants II not once not one smidgen
of corruption and actually towed the
despite fast and furious IRS Benghazi
and now they're excited excited about
lawyer-client privilege being broken for
the first time in American history with
regards to a presidential lawyer they
live in a fever dream Sean they can't
get over Watergate and they're desperate
desperate to get back to the days of
Watergate and the fact is they see their
mission as one thing Shawn to take down
a Republican president that's not the
job of the media but that's what they
think they are doing and they're
detached from reality because compare
that to what the average person outside
the bubble has lived through in the last
15 months and they're loving it from the
economy to Isis to the crushing of
illegal migration across the southern
border nobody Carol I think we're the
only show that has reported all the good
news and I put my list up I'll bring it
back this week please look it sure I I
just came back from LA and I'm meeting
with people in California who are
finally actually optimistic that they
can get some sanity back into the
People's Republic why because they saw a
president who's broken all the rules and
is bringing us back to where we should
be as a nation that's California short
but these people live in their little
cosseted Kevlar coated bubble and they
will never understand that they were
their fuel is hatred short pure hatred
what do you what advice do you give the
president Michelle it does he's his best
advocate he's his best spokesperson he's
his best defender does he go out
directly now to the American people does
he just let his lawyers go out there and
do it what would you recommend well he
has always trusted his own instincts and
clearly there's been a house cleaning
house cleaning I think that was in order
and and he's just going to the you know
let Trump be Trump I think that's what's
going to have to happen here and as long
as he has a direct conduit to the
American people and that's why it's
important that he keeps speaking his
mind whether it's
impromptu at tax reform conferences
where he throws out the talking points
and instead talks about what people were
very concerned about at that moment
which was the invasion that continues to
happen on our border and surely good
yes--that's worker yeah one thing for
the president
we need more surrogates he's the best
communicator but when I was in the white
hat it was just Shaun me Kelly Anne and
Sarah we need everybody out there
Stephen Miller Peter Navarro more
surrogates telling the success story
okay guys great advice